I don't know like maybe you guys don't  understand this but the majority of  females have been essayed in some way or  they're scared to go out at night time  or they carry their keys in their hand  so the way the majority  wait that doesn't mean that doesn't mean  like to the extreme but it is a lot of  women have feel scared by men okay but  if you're gonna if you're gonna say  words and they're not true I have to  like call you out wait I'm sure there's  statistics  so okay but not not the scared one you  said the majority have been sexually  assaulted yeah that doesn't mean so and  so I I know what stat you're talking  about and it's the two out of three  women have been sexual like I I know  what stat it is and it's not true they  they they they include things like if  you're drunk having sex you've been  sexually assaulted